thank you before I begin I want to  apprise everyone of an incident in the  Strait of Hormuz today involving USS  boxer and Navy amphibious assault ship  the boxer took defensive action against  an Iranian drone which had closed into a  very very near distance approximately  1,000 yards ignoring multiple calls to  stand down and was threatening the  safety of the ship and the ship's crew  the drone was immediately destroyed this  is the latest of many provocative and  hostile actions by Iran against vessels  operating in international waters the  United States reserves the right to  defend our personnel our facilities and  interests and calls upon all nations to  condemn Iran's attempts to disrupt  freedom of navigation and global  commerce I also call on other nations to  protect their ships as they go through  the Strait and to work with us in the  future thank you very much I thought you  should know that